ben affleck and jennifer lopez appear to
be blending their families together
seamlessly it feels really good and it's
really nice but i'm so happy a source
tells e.t that ever since the lovebirds
introduced their children to each other
they've all been spending more and more
time together and getting along great i
do love that i love it ben shares three
kids fifteen-year-old violet
twelve-year-old seraphina and
nine-year-old samuel with his ex-wife
jennifer garner while jen has two kids
13 year old twins max and emmy whom she
shares with her ex-husband mark anthony
e.t source explains quote it's been fun
for them to do activities as a blended
family and the kids are enjoying getting
to know each other better jen and ben
are both hands-on parents and their kids
are their number one priority so it's
important for them to do things as a
unit that make their families happy i'm
thrilled i am really happy the oscar
winner and the triple threat were
spotted out and about in la with their
kids a few times over the weekend on
friday they went to the pantages theater
to see hamilton followed by a day out
together at the magic castle on saturday
and an eyewitness tells et that the
couple their kids and ben's mom visited
the castle as guests of one of the
magicians quote everyone seemed to enjoy
themselves especially the children the
whole group seemed like a happy family
who were having a good time it was worth
it and jen is going the extra mile to
bond with her man's kids earlier this
month jlo picked out made by mary
jewelry for emmy violet and seraphina a
source told et at the time that the
necklaces she got them are from the
brand's birth flower collection and she
chose a february violet december holly
and january carnation to match their
birthday months
i can't stop smiling of course things
have been heating up between the 52 year
old hustler star and the 49 year old
batman actor since they rekindled their
romance in april and another source
tells et that the pair are quote
definitely ready to take their
relationship to the next level and move
in together very soon
quote their goal is to be one big happy
family they both feel like this was
really meant to be everyone is getting
along great and things are really
working out for them on so many levels
and the source adds that the families
hanging out together feels very natural
to everyone quote jen is very in love
with ben ben is taken with jen and
equally smitten
[Music]
you